you can do some crazy stuff with options
like 10K to 90k zero days to expiration
options or zero DTE have exploded in
popularity in the last year they allow
investors to bet on stock market moves
within the same day which can result in
big wins and big losses this is one of
the biggest shifts I've seen in markets
of the past decade here's why zero DTE
options have taken off despite being
some of the riskiest in the entire
market so I got into Dr GTE in 20 during
the whole like lockdown Drayson little
graduated from college in 2021 and has
been trading options fulltime for about
a year he lives in Las Vegas so his day
typically starts around 5:30 a.m. an
hour before the Market opens on the East
Coast first things first is I'll head
over to Twitter that's where I get all
my news on big news days like when
inflation data is released he says it's
easier to spot a trend in the market you
can see a massive move into and from
that PC number which he said says is the
best time to trade Zer DTE in 1 minute I
had made $100 he says he usually bets a
few thousand per trade one of his
biggest one-day profits was about
$14,000 and biggest loss was about
$112,000 it's like Euphoria like it's
like winning a lottery but then you also
have your crazy lows zero DTE options
expire the same day they're purchased
which is why they are some of the most
sensitive to changes in the Stock's
price so that's why you can see them zip
fire or crash incredibly quickly but
that's also part of the reason they're
so appealing to Traders your upside
potential is infinite it could be 500%
it could be 1,000% Traders are also
drawn to zero DTE options because
they're cheaper than longer dated
contracts but often the odds are stacked
against you a lot of these retail
Traders do end up losing a lot of money
Dron says some of his biggest losses
occurred in his first year of trading I
think I probably lost at the time during
2020 upwards of like
$65,000 and this was when I was a
full-time student I was an entrepreneur
before I had made some money from um
e-commerce I lost 20 30% of it and it's
just very uh it just feels feels really
bad to be honest with you but he says
the possibility of big wins enticed him
to keep trading the thing is with a 9
to-5 it's not scalable you only make so
much during these hours compared to
trading where you take one crazy trade
like just one trade and you make a
million dollars this type of options
trading has long been reserved for
professionals with sophisticated
technology and tools but in the last few
years retail Traders have played a big
role in driving zero DTE trading volumes
to record highs it's really become a
viral phenomenon you know when I was
looking at hashtags for Zer DTE online
there are tens of thousands of mentions
of zero DTE just this year alone a few
years ago there were no such mentions
part of the reason is that options
exchanges expanded zero DTE contracts to
every day of the week last year to
capitalize on this boom and that just
Unleashed a frenzy of activity um and
Traders I was talking to were saying
we've never seen something take off the
way zero DTE trading has many of these
retail Traders started with meme stocks
this is really the continuation of a
trend the past few years as more people
have entered markets where they want to
bet on Sports they want to bet at the
casino and they also want to bet on
stocks but some experts think all this
betting could mean trouble for the
market there's a lot of concern from a
lot of Industry analysts and pundits
that suggest that zero DTE could kind of
bring about an end of day scenario in
markets that's because when professional
traders buy or sell options they also
buy or sell stocks to hedge their
positions that creates worries that if
there is a big move in the market and
all of a sudden someone's doing a ton of
buying and selling of options that could
Ripple over into the stock market for
example during the mem stock Mania there
were concerns that options activity was
exacerbating the volatility I think a
lot of the fear now is that zero DTE
volumes will put the market in the same
position the odds of that happening is a
lot lower than in a situation uh like
GameStop or M Mania while this concern
is hotly debated on Wall Street kochuba
says zero DTE options have become such a
large part of trading that when there's
an unexplainable move in the Market you
can look at the Zer DTE volumes uh and
movement in zero DTE and understand that
this could be driving those Strange
Behaviors I wouldn't regret anything I
honestly find it um it has taught me a
lot more things and has leveled me up as
a person rather than pull me down with
the money he made from Trading he says
he was able to buy one of my dream cars
the AMG
GTR get back to my family travel around
the world and then I bought a Rolex so
that was pretty cool
he says his goal for next year is to
make six figures every month and launch
an options trading course you're going
to have your lows you're going to have
your highs but as long as you just keep
moving forward you'll eventually get to
your end
[Music]
goal